j'étais folle de lui et bien oui je
parle fort parce que je suis heureux et
j'ai envie de le crier
il était d'une tendresse infinie
je t'aime
aussi c'est plus sage d'attendre un peu
à mon âge moi j'ai plus envie d'être
sage
tu vas pas regretter de faire tout ça
pour moi
[Musique]
quand ton mari pourquoi tu es toujours
que je me plaque de toi
j'ai réfléchi et on va rester là pour
Noël c'est beaucoup plus simple tu as
besoin de voir du monde on a besoin de
voir personne on est bien tous les deux
je te veux que pour moi
grec c'est arrangé pour me rendre la vie
impossible et vous suivez
[Musique]
pas la moindre de mes questions
je vous préviens le chemin va être long
on devrait dire des choses qui font
souffrir
c'est une guerre
[Musique]